This brings us to the conclusion of Unit 5.
We've seen several examples of authentication protocols
and focused on TLS as the most widely-used protocol that's used for every secure web session.
The first thing I hope you take away from this is that designing cryptographic protocols is really hard.
The details matter and the way things are implemented matters.
TLS is a protocol that's built on SSL that's been around for over 17 years.
It still has new vulnerabilities being discovered
and people learning new ways to exploit them.
The other key lesson is attacks get better, they never get worse,
even if the initial attack seems to be only theoretical and not be easy to exploit,
there are often ways that clever people will figure out ways to exploit those attacks.
In Unit 6, we'll look at other things you can do with cryptographic protocols.
This unit focused all on authentication and communication,
but there are lots and lots of other things we can do with cryptography.
Some of those are quite interesting, and I hope you'l be back for Unit 6 to learn about them.